[Music]
one of the big predictions people are
making in 2018 is that graph QL will
make restful api is obsolete in today's
episode we'll learn how to build a graph
QL API from scratch using Apollo server
2.0 and node KS if you're new here make
sure to LIKE and subscribe and I want to
send a huge thank you out to Arjun
yellow man celli he's the mastermind
behind the code in this video and if you
need a talented developer in Denver he
comes highly recommended so let's kick
things off by talking about graph QL
from a very high level imagine you have
an angular app that communicates with a
bunch of different back-end data sources
traditionally you would do this with
either a REST API or a client-side SDK
when you hit a restful endpoint it's the
server that determines the shape of the
data that gets sent back to the client
what happens is that you'll hit a rest
one point and it will respond with a
bunch of data that you don't know
anything about and that you don't need
graph QL is a query language that solves
this problem by sitting in between your
back-end and front-end it allows the
server to define exactly what data is
available and it allows the client to
only request the data that it actually
needs to provide the user experience
what's really cool is that you can use
it with any back-end data source and
this video will use fire store and set
up a node J a server with Apollo to
deliver the API this video is a two part
series in this first installment we will
set up the back-end API and in the
second part we will use angular to
consume this API from the front end when
you set up a graph QL API it provides
this really nice playground that you can
use to start sending requests and this
just works out of the box what we're
going to do in the code is set up
interfaces that describe the data that's
available on the server this is super
powerful because the client can probe
the backend in advance to find out what
types are available and how they can be
requested this means you get amazing
developer tooling even on a foreign API
because you know exactly what's
available and how it can be requested
you can see here I requested all the
interface names and the ones we're
interested in our tweet and user let's
say we want to request all of the tweets
from our database but we only want the
ID and the number of likes all we need
to do is type out the shape of our data
on the left and then send it to the
server on the right and it will respond
with J
Sahn in the exact shape that we
requested and this is live data you're
looking at that lives in the firestore
database but it can come from any data
source or even multiple data sources at
the same time the tweets also have a
text property so if we want to include
text in our request we just add that to
the interface and it returns the text
from the database this can be extremely
useful if you have relational data that
you need to join from multiple sources
which is commonly the case with no
sequel databases let's imagine we want
to query a user plus all of that users
tweets which live in a completely
different collection and firestore you
can pass arguments to graph QL which in
this case will be the user ID then we'll
get autocomplete for all the properties
available so if we want to just pull the
screen name we can do that easily but
tweets can also belong to a user and
it's a property on the user interface so
we can apply it here and then request
some data about the tweets that we want
to return back that will only belong to
this user so that's really only the tip
of the iceberg with graph QL but the
main takeaway is that it allows you to
request data in exactly the way it
should be consumed in the front end
which is a big difference from rest
api's now we're ready to write some code
but first I have some really good news
just a couple days ago nodejs became
available on the App Engine standard
runtime which means you can use it for
free and it's super easy to integrate
into a firebase project I first want to
point out that you can find the full
setup instructions on the github repo
for this video but I do want to point
out a few the more important parts I'll
be writing this in typescript but the
code is fully compatible with vanilla
Jas if you prefer that the first thing I
want to do is install a palo server 2.0
as well as graph QL then to make things
fully compatible with typescript there's
a few extra things we added to the TS
config so make sure to grab the TS
config from the repo from here we can
install firebase admin and then we'll
need to go to the firebase console and
download our service account you can
find it under settings and then go to
service accounts and then download it
into the Roo the project as service
account JSON I have set up an indexed es
file and in this file I'm first going to
import a few dependencies starting with
firebase admin and then a reference to
our service account and then we'll
initialize the app with that service
account
that gives us full access to the data
and firestore from here we'll import
Apollo server and graph QL will also
bring in Apollo error and validation so
we can handle errors gracefully on the
server there are two main pieces to a
graph QL API the first one is your graph
QL type definitions which is where you
write actual graph QL code to define the
shape of the data that's available on
the server the second half of this
puzzle are your resolvers this is where
you tell graph QL how to return the
actual data to the client through the
API so first let's start by defining our
type definitions you can define an
object by calling type with the name of
the object and then there's a number of
built-in data types for example ID is
just a string that is supposed to be
unique then you have common data types
that you would expect like string
integer and things like that when you
put brackets around something that means
that it should return an array of that
interface you might also notice the
exclamation point after each property
that just means the API will always
promise to return that data type it
won't return a null value so a user can
have an array of tweets which we've
modeled here but a tweet can only have
one user so we'll set some properties
for our tweet object but this time we'll
type the user to the user schema that we
just defined in the previous step but if
you look in the database you'll notice
that our actual user data doesn't have
any tweets objects nested on it tweets
are their own isolated collection that
are completely decoupled from users
that's important to make note of because
in the next step we'll use resolvers to
combine all this stuff together now the
last thing we need in our schema is the
query which can be thought of as like
the main entry point into your API in
this case we can enter the API through
tweets or we can enter it through the
user with their user ID at this point
everything that's available to be
fetched on our API is well-defined but
we still need a method to actually
retrieve this data for that we'll define
an object called resolvers where each
property in this object matches one of
our interfaces data that already exists
on the firestore document can be
inferred automatically but remember we
don't have any tweets available on the
actual user itself so we need to write a
method that can resolve that data in
firebase this is really easy because we
can use the admin database called the
tweets collection
and then just query where the user ID
equals the user ID on this object then
we call get to return that as a promise
and that'll be a snapshot and the final
step is to just map that snapshot down
to its actual raw data object if this
code fails at runtime we want to throw
an error to handle it gracefully which
we can do inside of the try catch block
by throwing an Apollo error tweets will
follow a very similar process in this
case we just need to return a single
firestore document because every tweet
has an Associated user ID but we want to
be able to return additional data if the
user requests it on their graph QL query
the last resolver that we need is the
query this defines how we get the data
for the route documents being that tweet
and the user tweets are a collection so
we can simply return those as a
firestore collection so what we're
looking at here is just firebase 101
we're pointing to a collection and then
retrieving it as an array of documents
the user query is also very similar but
the main difference is we're passing an
argument to the method being the user ID
we can access the argument data as the
second argument in this method so now we
can retrieve our user based on the user
ID that's passed in by whoever is making
the graph QL query it's very possible
that they will pass in an ID that
doesn't exist so we want to handle that
with a validation error if you remember
earlier we used exclamation points to
only return valid types if that user
doesn't exist we need to return a
validation error instead okay just a
couple of lines of code left
we just need to combine these two pieces
together by passing them to an Apollo
server instance the Apollo server feels
just like an Express Jas server we just
call listen on it and we're good to go
all you need to do at this point is
compile your typescript code which you
can do with the TSC command or there's a
command in the main repo when you run
the script you can pull up localhost and
get the playground to start sending
queries to your API but we're not just
going to stop here there's this really
cool thing called Apollo engine that can
handle things like caching and tracing
and it does it all in a really nice UI
you'll first need to register for an
Apollo Engine API key then all you need
to do is add it to your Apollo server
config and you're good to go
this gives you access to a dashboard
where you can monitor all the queries to
see the exact latency of each one and
also inspect errors in real time and
let's also go ahead and deploy our app
to a production server assuming you have
the Google Cloud command-line tools
installed all you have to do is create
an app damo file with the nodejs 8
runtime in it run g-cloud app deploy and
your graph QL api is now available for
the world to use I'm gonna go ahead and
wrap things up there if this video
helped you please like and subscribe and
stay tuned for the second installment
where we build out the front-end and
angular with the Apolo angular library
and if you want to take things to the
next level consider becoming a pro
member at angular firebase com thanks
for watching and I'll talk to you soon